you
[Music]
we're happy to agree with David Carter
who's a celebrity we used to be a book
celebrity in theory and it's now also
and I guess you can ask questions and he
might you might just ignore you exactly
yeah so um thanks very much it's fun to
inaugurate a room for those who prefer
those from the I see some theory people
in the audience and I'll have to
disappoint you that's not what I'll be
talking about today although I'll
probably come back and give another
theory talk sometime later
so xkcd has this book they published of
describing everything using only the
thousand most common words in the
English language and they said a
challenge to the academics my department
to do the same so this is sort of me I
basically like to study tools that help
people manage information and sort of a
general theme in the work is that
computers are making people dumb and we
need to change the computers to allow
people to be smart the way people are in
particular people are very talented
masters of information we have lots of
domain experts and people who know what
they want to do with their information
and they have their own ways of wanting
to organize or visualize or explain that
information but they're really limited
by current tools to whatever the
developer thought was the right way to
organize the information and that just
doesn't work because people can't
express what they know and can't
organize things in ways that makes sense
to them and so this is a problem this is
not a machine learning problem okay
there I mean just about everything as a
machine learning problem these days but
this is not a machine learning problem
because if people are prevented from
putting information into the computer
then it's not there and so the computer
cannot magically cause that information
to materialize instead I focus on tools
that let the computer capture more
information from the human in order to
make the organization better and I work
in sort of two spaces one is to look at
online discussion tools which is what
I'll be focusing on today I also do work
on letting end-users build their own
information management applications
which is a whole sort of separate line
of work so really my picture
Jules is that you've got this very smart
human being with a very complicated
picture in their head and then we give
them this very limited interface where
they can only express a tiny fraction of
what they know and understand and then
we throw all of this computation look
very carefully at the tiny bit of
information that they presented and of
course the computer figures out
something entirely different because
there just isn't enough signal from the
human so I'm going to talk today about
how to bring these ideas of richer
information models and more information
towards online discussion I'm going to
be linking first at richer information
structures in particular how to use
annotation and summarization to improve
the quality of online discussions and
then I'll be looking also at richer
workflows that let people have a better
chance of controlling what they receive
through mailing lists we'll be looking
specifically at online harassment and
how people can manage that more
effectively the recipients not the
sender's and then we'll also be looking
at automation of general social media
and in all of these the theme is well
that's interesting
hello in all of these okay after
remember to press something overthrown
the the last time I gave a talk at
Microsoft my computer rebooted in the
middle for a Windows Update now
hopefully that's not gonna happen again
so the theme of all of these tools is
using the computer really as just a
smart blackboard it's the medium for the
information and it's not providing any
real intelligence beyond what the human
brings so let's first talk about models
if we look at online discussion tools
today we see these giant streams of
posts and replies to those posts and the
numbers are staggering
you know you can have hundreds of
comments on a news article thousands of
comments on a Facebook post there are
half a million comments on certain
YouTube videos
do you suppose anybody has read those
comments
probably not
commenting offers an online discussion
in general offers a really impoverished
user interface which just is a linear
stream of posts and replies to those
posts and pretty much all we've moved
beyond that linear structure is the
ability to like or to like or tack
things in a particular post and there
are sometimes in certain platforms these
opaque tools for filtering the content
in some way and showing you only a
subset of it majority voting on reddit
the mysterious Facebook feed trending
topics and so forth
but the result of this giant stream of
posts that you can't control is
information overload and I think what
you get a lot of the times is right only
common streams so everybody is
commenting and nobody is reading
comments because there's too much and
you can't find the stuff that you would
actually want to pay attention to and
indeed what we've been seeing for
several years is new sites at other
sites choosing to turn off comments
entirely because they find that they're
actually a negative value they the the
people at popular science did a study
and they found out that people reading
the comments on their articles developed
less trust in science as a result of the
trolling and negativity on those comment
feeds so they turn them off I'm hoping
we can do something better and so for
the first half of this talk I want to
tell you about two sort of richer ways
of organizing discussion to make it more
useful so the first is a paper that is
comics comes out of a paper and work
that we started into 2012 on placing
discussion in the margins and this we
looked at specifically in the context of
classroom discussion so one place where
discussion forums can be really useful
is in the classroom where students can
ask each other questions and are not
limited to interaction with the
professor in class they can get answers
from other students which provides a
scale a scalability that you don't have
if there's only one faculty answering
you get this archival record of
knowledge that can be helpful to the
students and also the faculty by
observing the discussion may gain some
insight into
what is confusing the students and what
needs to be improved in their teaching
there's also some interesting work from
the education community that shows that
discussion of education material is
actually the best way for people to
learn it
Michelle Chi developed this taxonomy and
this hierarchy of different kinds of
learning so there's passively listening
to a talk the way that you are now I
noticed that nobody is taking notes
which is just terrible because active
note-taking improves your retention and
learning of material even better is to
do exercises and I'll be handing out a
few at the end of the talk and best of
all is to discuss the material with
other students to work collaboratively
on solving problems and explaining
things to each other and she did some
very nice control experiments in the
study of mathematics that showed this
improving quality of learning so
discussion forums have the potential to
generate those sorts of productive
discussions to help people learn
unfortunately discussion forums have a
sort of context problem right you're
reading your textbook and you get
confused so you go to the discussion
forum and you post a question and now
you're online so maybe it's you check
Facebook and do some other things you
get you start multitasking in the forum
itself you have to hunt around to see if
somebody has asked your question before
if there's an answer to it when you do
the post you have to describe the
context of your question in great detail
so that somebody can understand it well
enough to answer it if you want to be
helpful you have to go hunting through
the forum for questions that you might
answer when you know maybe some of the
questions are about material you haven't
even reached yet in the textbook and
there's no structure there's again
there's just this big linear series of
posts that nobody can navigate so our
idea was that the content of the course
that textbook or the lecture notes
provide a context and we could keep that
context in the discussion by having the
discussions in the margins of the text
instead of having them in a separate
discussion forum so we built NBD which
stands for nota bene and it's a plain
old threaded discussion forum but it
runs in the margins of the document that
is being discussed
it's a standard website the faculty sets
up a class upload some PDF documents or
points at some HTML documents and then
the students when they log in get a
sidebar where a forum is situated and
discussion can happen and so this is a
picture of the interface on the left is
the content and you can see these little
boxes that show places where students
have chosen to annotate and we've chosen
sort of an inbox model so you have sort
of subject lines at the top associated
with the different comments and then
when you click on one you get the
details of the of the entire discussion
and that's a threaded sort of reply
based discussion model because we want
discussion to happen now you can
immediately see some interesting things
so here is a post whose content is how
did we get three from one imagine if you
saw a post like that in a standard
discussion forum what use would it be
right you would have no understanding of
the question but because there is this
linkage to the original content it's
very clear what the question is asking
the way it's used is pretty
straightforward if you want to make a
post you highlight a section of the
document and it opens up a box in which
you can make a post once the posts are
there if you see one you can click on a
box and be taken to the post you can
click on a post and be taken to the box
and when you're reading a post you can
hit reply and participate in the
discussion so this had a number of
benefits going back to the thing to the
problems I talked about before this lets
you stay in the flow of your reading
without exiting the document and it lets
you see the discussion of what you're
reading right now so if you're confused
you just look in the side and you see
what other students were confused about
and maybe one of them already addressed
the thing that's confusing you
conversely if you understand the thing
you're reading you can look to the side
and see if somebody's confused and you
can immediately answer their question
and and help them out the context is
clear as I just showed you
furthermore the annotations can actually
provide a sort of a heat map for the
faculty member right where are the
students putting their comments what are
they confused about and I'll come back
to that later when I talk about the work
that we're doing now now annotation is
not a new idea
sorry
okay annotation is not a new idea this
is a 2000 year old hypertext called the
babylonian talmud this is built off of a
document called the Mishnah which was
published about 2,500 years ago and that
is the content of the original document
and a few hundred years later when they
decided they needed to interpret what
was in that very terse original document
they annotated it and they wrote lots
and lots of commentary around the
original document several hundred years
after that it was decided that the
annotations were ambiguous and they
needed to annotate the annotations and
so there's a whole nother layer that he
merged in the Middle Ages and finally a
fourth layer of interpretation happened
in the 1700s and so forth so 2500 year
old hypertext not a new idea to have
your conversation your discussions in
context more modern example is Don Knuth
concrete mathematics textbook he
actually when he was drafting this
handed it out to the students and had
them write comments in the margins and
when he published the book he actually
curated those marginal comments and put
them into the margins of the publication
and this is one of my favorite text
books it is just full of life because of
all of the the kinds of commentary of
the students watch out you know you may
not think this is interesting now but
just wait five pages and then you'll see
why he's telling you about it now and so
you really get the student voice
concrete mathematics by Don Knuth ok all
right so how did we assess this tool NBD
has been surprisingly successful it's a
horrible clunky system that was built by
a meki student who was teaching
themselves to program while they were
building it nevertheless it's been used
by about 700 classes around the world at
sixty different universities we're
approaching two million comments or
actually may have passed it already from
60,000 students in just about every
imaginable topic of learning and we've
seen frequently reuse people like what
they're getting and they use it again
statistics of sort of growth in number
of comments per year since 2015 we've
been doing a collaboration with UC Davis
that has generated an
singing amount of comments because their
classes have a thousand students in them
every quarter so I've broken those out
but basically lots of universities lot
generating lots of comments and on many
many different topics from Shakespeare
to material science to biology to
philosophy and and so forth
back in 2012 before all the success we
did a focused analysis of the first
class to use envy which was actually at
an MIT it was a professor named Sanjoy
Mahajan who was teaching a course on
approximation and he was actually a
perfect subject because he had already
been requiring students to annotate his
textbook in paper like he they would
actually hand in cut he would hand out
chapters and they would have to hand
back copies and he would spend the whole
night before the lecture reading all of
the comments that the students had
written on the lecture on the textbook
so that and then revising his his
content so this was an insanely
dedicated faculty member who loved the
idea of not having to do all of that in
paper at the last minute and so what did
we see
we saw extensive in-depth discussion we
saw that about three-quarters of the
questions that students were asking were
resolved by other students in under an
hour they generated about fourteen this
was about a hundred students they
generated about fourteen thousand
annotations over the course of the
semester many of them were not
standalone annotations but were parts of
discussions many of those discussions
were quite long and they appeared all
over the document in terms of the
content about a quarter of it was just
substantive commentary on the material
itself ways to say things better a third
was questions about concepts and about
the meaning of the text and then if the
the remainder was was answers to those
questions and random random humor and so
forth in terms of who answered the
questions about half of the questions
were answered by students in the same
thread but interestingly enough a tenth
of the questions were answered by
students in a different thread so rather
than being organized by thread the
discussion was organized by where it was
in the document so students would
actually refer to other nearby threads
in what they were discussing faculty
answered some of the questions as well
no there is no there is no that's in our
to-do list but there is currently no way
to sort of hyperlink between different
threads or to have a annotation another
thing we're talking about is having
annotations that point to multiple parts
of the document if you want to compare
things you're asking too many questions
no sorry go ahead well I've count atom
collide that's awesome okay so right so
actually in the earliest version of NB
we had a general discussion thing at the
top which we just deserted a blank page
nobody used it so we got rid of it
relatively early because NB is
contextual it's not really good for
logistics discussions that the Piazza is
a great tool for that sort of thing but
no we've been so we've been focused on
discussions of the course content itself
okay and of course in an ideal world you
would be able to do both of these in one
environment so that you didn't have to
keep switching back and forth what did
users say well they loved the amount of
in-depth discussion that they were
getting and they loved the sort of
collective intelligence of being able to
access all of the other students
knowledge in order to understand the
material yeah this may be a messy
specific but they really like to see
that they weren't the only confused
student but that in fact everybody else
was also asking questions helped them
feel less stupid faculty were also very
happy they felt that the tool itself was
very good that the comic quality was
very high and they generally chose to
reuse the tool and this was despite this
really clunky code and interface what
they loved was that they felt they
really got better a sense of the
students that the students came alive
and even the shy ones were sort of
getting involved in this online
discussion they felt that real
conversations and debates were happening
that they couldn't conjure in the
classroom itself yes
so there is there are separate settings
so a student can post if the faculty
allows then the student can post
anonymous comments although they are not
anonymous to the faculty because we
didn't want to have to deal with
trolling inside of the class environment
but they're anonymous to other students
and so we found I mean there's not not
scientifically rigorous but we found
that in general MIT students preferred
to post anonymously and students at Olin
preferred to talk to each other by name
interesting we don't know quite what was
going on there
and they really liked that they could
sort of adapt the to focus on what was
confusing the students because of this
sort of heat map effect okay now a lot
of this was stuff that would happen with
any discussion forum right so can we
validate that having the context is
useful so Envy was working as a forum
but context should be better what was
the evidence well many people had tried
forums before and failed to get
meaningful conversations out of them so
here we had success so something
different so the only the only
difference was the context and
annotation aspect so we suspect that
that had some influence we also got
feedback that said that the context was
helpful that it allowed the faculty
discover areas of confusion in the text
itself and they could notice when
students were misinterpreting a
particular thing so they explicitly said
that it was an improvement over
traditional discussion boards we also
saw as I showed you at the beginning
these context-sensitive comments so it's
easier to ask your questions and have
people understand them we saw how
responses were synthesizing proximate
threads which could never happen in a
discussion forum we also found that
students were not printing their notes
at all which is weird because it's a lot
easier to read paper than it is to read
to read online so somehow what's the
benefit of reading online is that you
have access to the discussion forum
which you lose when you print so again a
sort of an indirect sign of value of the
comments we also decided to measure this
sorry there's also the value that the
students are now showing that they're
reading the material right so the
faculty can see that students are active
and this encourages students to act
read we also did an analysis of when
students are commenting right so you
could imagine that people read and then
they go and post comments but no in fact
this is sort of a normalized time line
over a student's reading session when
did they post their comments and you can
see that the comment was happening all
during the reading session and not at
the end so they were seeing things
responding to them or asking questions
in the middle of their reading without
losing the flow of their reading through
the text and so I think this generated a
critical mass for the discussion it
attracted eyeballs to a particular
thread at just the right time so the
summary here is that annotation can work
it produces substantial students student
teaching participation by everybody and
again NBD is a is a medium it's there's
no intelligence here it's just a
blackboard but it provides a richer
structure for the conversation yes yeah
that's a really interesting question let
me pause it for for so I went park it
for two slides and then I'll come back
to it so the key here is giving people
information in the right time and in the
right context so where are we trying to
take this well where we want to do we've
been working for several years more on
this project we're trying to analyze the
comments to understand more about
whether we can detect student confusion
automatically and we've actually
explored this question of whether to
keep the comments around when I started
this project I figured that we would use
this to create the perfect textbook and
then people wouldn't need to comment
anymore right but if you think about
this I cap hierarchy you want people to
discuss right you don't want the
textbook to be perfect you want
conversation so we did this experiment
where we took the comments from one year
and we found the long ones and then we
took the first post of the long comment
and we copied that into the following
year but without the following and we
discovered that that created
statistically long discussions in the
follow-on year so it's able it's
possible to actually stimulate
discussion of the material and that's
something that we want to carry farther
for
as well we're also looking at tools now
to measure student confusion and
engagement in the text and trying to
figure out ways to actually show
heatmaps rich or heat maps to the
faculty about you know the students seem
to be very confused here they seem to be
very bored here to allow them to make
revisions to improve the quality of the
teaching
we've got other projects in annotation
going on it SRU science that they
evolved so in machine learning tensor
flow but six months from now it might
look completely different or you know is
there isn't a planet yeah well so NB is
designed around content that isn't that
doesn't change I mean it's actually very
hard to keep track of where to move in
annotation if an HTML document is is
edited and and mcgann coming back to
this issue reuse of comments when if
somebody teaches a class again they
generally generate a new copy of the
class sometimes it'll import their old
material but they'll just have a clean
slate to start with because they want
students discussing things over again so
we never really tried to address this
question of how to preserve annotations
over a mutating content okay we did it
was half-baked and we never really
pushed it and in the rebuild and be that
we're doing right now we're trying to be
a little bit more thoughtful about how
that would work we want to be careful
about voting because we don't want to
discourage students from participating
in discussion yes
yes so in one of the very first uses of
this tool which was at Harvard professor
required students to annotate and he
very rapidly started getting a lot of
complaints from students who said that
they couldn't annotate because
everything had been said already this
was in a class of hundred students so
obviously they were wrong but in order
to address that problem we created
sectioning and so we've found that sort
of a reasonable section size of about 30
students works well and and B allows the
faculty member to just partition their
student into whatever sections they want
and then students only see the comments
from their own section now that raises
really interesting questions about well
maybe you want to promote certain
comments to full class visibility
because they're very interesting and so
forth and there's a lot more to talk
about there yeah so there's a little
common grading module in NBD that allows
faculty to actually assign grades to
comments we've also done some studies
that try to correlate like do people who
comment a lot get high grades in the
class or actually grade is not an
excellent measure because that that may
reflect sort of effort invested in the
class and so of course higher effort is
going to lead to higher learning gains
but we've done we've begun to do some
studies that look at learning gains with
there are these ways of sort of
normalized you you give students a test
at the beginning that helps you
normalize their current level of
understanding and then you can look at
how much they gain and understanding
over the course of the semester and this
is the kind of work that we're putting
that we've gotten an NSF proposal and to
do with UC Davis over the next few years
all right so I guess I'm a quarter way
through the talk and half way through
the time so we'll see we'll see what
happens next so the next kind of
structure that I want to talk about is
summarization so again with a million
comments you're not going to read them
all but it would be really nice if you
could get the gist of what was being
said about an article you can use
filtering or moderation but that really
doesn't govern guarantee coverage write
your own
gonna get some subset of the content and
who knows what was missing you may not
get all the perspectives or the key
ideas right if there's a popular
perspective and an unpopular perspective
than social moderation is going to
completely hide the unpopular
perspective and you won't see it at all
so wouldn't be nice if we could take
this giant discussion and create a
summary of it but who's gonna do the
summarization work and how will they do
it right who's going to summarize half a
million comments many people are willing
to write the post or write a comment but
nobody's willing to read an entire
discussion so can we somehow divvy up
that task of summarization so
collaborative summarization has been
done before if you think about it that's
what a wiki is right each Wikipedia
article is a collaborative summarization
of some piece of knowledge but wiki's
are not perfect for the task that we're
aiming at because that summary is not
connected to the discussion at all right
so Sakura has an answer wiki actually
where you can write a wiki response to a
to a particular question but it's not
part of the discussion so there's no
Providence where did the content of that
answer wiki come from you also have no
idea of how much of the discussion is in
that summary and no way of accessing
more detail and in the summary you lose
the individual voices of the discussion
and have less motivation to contribute
so what we did was build a tool called
Wickham that tries to kind of combine
the good aspects of forums and wiki's
thus the name you start with a long
discussion and it Wickham provides a
workflow to allow this summer this
discussion to be summarized slowly
basically anyone reading a comment or a
thread can summarize the little bit that
they've read and that summary then
replaces the individual posts that they
are summarizing but anytime you want you
can expand that summary in order to see
the posts that were summarized so this
lets one person summarize a little bit
of the discussion and it's sort of
topology preserving because what you
summarize is a is a little subtree of
the discussion and it just collapses
that subtree into a single node at the
bottom of the discussion tree and so you
create this leaf which is now the parent
of all of the things
summarising now as more and more people
do this you may eventually summarize
away all of the original posts but now
people can start to summarize the
summaries right and then summarize the
summaries of the summaries and so you
get this ever-shrinking representation
of the discussion which creates a sort
of recursive summarization process that
eventually summarizes the entire
discussion into a single node at the top
but it's an expandable summary so we
call that a summary tree right I'm sort
of a richer structure that lets you
investigate the discussion at whatever
level of detail you choose you can
expand the parts that you think are
interesting in order to find out more
about them so compared to a wiki Wickham
shows you what has been summarized and
what does not it's in the display and it
connects the summaries to the discussion
that has been summarized and it also
breaks the summarization task into these
manageable pieces so that in different
people can do it although we have found
that this breaking up of the tasks is
useful even for an individual who wants
to summarize something by themselves yes
rapidly in the thready
sense top topologically close this
actually top eloped apology so Wickham
was originally aimed at threaded
discussions so you would be generally
doing is summarizing a bunch of replies
to the same comment and so you'd be
shrinking things up from the leaves now
you can also summarize any sort of bunch
of disconnected items and they just get
drawn together into a sort of a a single
a single tree node so that's our future
work so I'm in the old version of within
the version of Wickham that we built the
the youth was to summarize a sort of a
finished discussion but I have a master
student who's going to be spending the
next year on integrating summarization
into the discussion process itself so
that you can start replying to summaries
and so forth
so here's just some little snaps you can
play with Wickham it's online at Wickham
org but this is sort of a just a quick
snapshot of the of the summarization
interface you basically select a bunch
of comments over here and it gives you
this box which shows the comments and
allows you to write a summary it
includes some very nice functionality
there's this tree visualization on the
left to let you kind of find this the
the blue and the orange referred to
summarize and on summarized parts of the
discussion so you can find a section to
summarize it also includes this editing
modal for summarizing groups of comments
within that editing modal you can quote
individual posts and cite them and those
become live links within the summary we
also try to guide people to do
summarization of the right stuff by
highlighting things that we think are
important so this is a limited use of
machine learning within the tool we also
put a max length restriction in order to
prevent the summary from being longer
than the original posts because we don't
want to get into an infinite loop so
this means that you still have all the
forum benefits where everybody can
contribute their own perspective but has
the downside of all this redundancy and
the need to read the entire argument
we've combined it with the aspects of a
wiki where the community can create a
short consensus article
and remove all of that redundancy but at
the same time we give you this ability
to expand and dig down into more and
more detail so it's a very reasonable
question and I'll point to two things
right so first of all we know that
people have an incentive to discuss
because of all of those posts that we
see in discussion tools we also see
through Wikipedia that there is at least
some group of people who have an
interest in curating knowledge right and
so you don't need everybody to be
involved in the summarization process
but you need a group of people who have
that motivation and this may vary from
community to community so how do we
evaluate this we wanted to evaluate two
things we wanted to evaluate the
summarization process how easy is it to
summarize and we also wanted to evaluate
the summarization product is the
resulting summary useful so to evaluate
the process we took three long
discussions and from each we selected
enough comments that they require about
40 minutes of reading time at a normal
speed and that means they were about
8,000 words and we did these two
evaluations one of the process and one
of the product who valued the process we
got a bunch of participants and we had
each of them spend some time learning
the tool and then do two different
summarization tasks first they've had to
summarize one of these discussions using
Google Docs which is a wiki then they
had to summarize there another
discussion using wickham so Google Docs
was our control and each person in the
group built on the work that the
previous person in their group had done
on that particular article so this is
what things looked like starting in
Wickham with nothing summarized we
pasted the same discussion into Google
Docs to get that wiki environment and
then we leave people go so we got this
partially complete summary in Wickham
and in Google Docs we got this mess okay
because a plain old wiki is not great
for for incremental summarization of
material in terms of the results here we
see solid lines which shows how progress
in summarization of Wickham articles
over over a given number of users and
the
- lines we see summarization in the
Google Doc condition where you can see
that the progress kind of flattens out
and they never reach full summarization
of the articles length so if the length
reaches zero then it is fully summarized
okay so so down you can think of the one
- the version of this right so this
means that it's it's 100% of the
original length of the discussion then
it shrinks to zero percent of the length
of the original discussion so that's the
product question so let me get to that
in just a minute so we wanted to know
about the process so we found that
people did not like it so Wickham is
actually a wiki so anybody can edit a
summary after it's been created but
nobody did okay it seems that in this
context at least people did not like
editing each other's work
unlike Wikipedia say users also reported
that as they were trying to summarize
they had to spend a lot of time just
reading through the Google Doc in order
to figure out the state of the summary
process which is not surprising because
google doc didn't show you the state of
the summary process we encourage people
to like you know cross out things when
they summarize them and otherwise but
the signals were very poor people really
felt that Wickham improved this
summarization workflow and they would be
you know they really liked the fact that
summarizing everything seemed
overwhelming but just summarizing a
little bit was a simple task and so
that's what they did they also really
liked the provenance aspect that the way
in which you can cite paragraphs and
posts is very useful to have a sense of
why is this valid summary did it do a
good job of capturing what's underneath
so we also needed to evaluate the
product as you just asked about and so
what we did was in the full discussion
before we started anything we identified
12 topics that were substantial within
the discussion and you remember these
were very long discussions so we were
actually having that people summarized
only a subset of it so we found six of
the topics that were in the part that
they were summarizing and six topics
that were not
in the part that they were summarizing
then we brought in people who are not
involved with the summarization process
and we asked them to look at the summary
for a limited amount of time which would
prevent them from Regis reading
everything and they then so they
attendance to sort of skim the summary
both the Wickham summary and the Google
Docs summary for their two separate
tests and also the unsub Erised
discussion as a third as a third
condition and then we asked them to
select which of the twelve discussion
points they actually remembered from
their examination of the summary and
unfortunately with such a small
population we did not get the
statistical significance that we wanted
but in Wickham the precision was highest
the recall was highest and the f1 score
was highest compared to the other two
conditions and I'd like to go back and
get a larger population in order to
validate that how did people use the
summaries well some just sort of some
did breadth-first search some did
depth-first search it's a tree so
there's different ways to explore a tree
they felt that it was very helpful to
have this summary structure in the
Google Doc again the summary was a big
mess but with Wickham there was the
structure that helped them navigate and
understand what the content was right
with these giant discussions there was
this large amount of text but the
summary made it simple to understand the
big the big picture now when we
submitted this reviewer to spoke up it
really was a review or two and said that
we had not done a good job of testing
this tool because Google Docs is such a
terrible tool for summarization it
wasn't a fair control but in fact that's
exactly the point
right that wiki's do not provide good
good scaffolding for summarization work
and we could do better right so the
study isn't to say our tool is the best
tool it's to say that we can do much
better than we are doing now in
supporting people to do this kind of
summarization work so looking forward
from this tool we want to think about
better ways of presenting and navigating
the summer tree summary tree we want to
think about how to gather
it in unthreaded discussion when there
is no tree how do you gather things
together and this may indeed involve
some machine learning that could be
summarized together or alternatively
we're also thinking about letting people
separating out the grouping tasks from
the summarization task let people sort
of tag different posts with topics or
gather them into groups and let somebody
else take a group and summarize it um
we're also trying to think about how to
deal with the fact that sometimes a
thread is not coherent right somebody
may reply to a thread with something
completely irrelevant and so for that
case you really want to break that
thread off there and create a separate
summary node for it we're also
considering now as I said the real-time
discussion and being able to summarize
while the discussion is happening and
then start replying to summaries instead
of having to read through the entire
discussion we've been gun doing some
field experiments with the Wikimedia
Foundation we're studying their request
for comments process and how people need
to summarize larger discussions in order
to decide what to do on Wikipedia and
also there are some digital democracy
work my student Amy who led this work
spent several months several weeks in
Madrid at a hackathon helping them use
they have a very active sort of citizen
Parliament connection if enough if
enough citizens contribute to their
online forum then Parliament has to take
up the topic and so they're very
interested in these tools for for
democratic use I'm also interested in
integrating this summarization process
with the annotation process one sort of
grows things and one one kind of shrinks
them and I think they could work very
well together so now we've looked at two
richer discussion models annotation and
summarization and both of them if you
think about it are yes here's how you
use a computer maybe the first law is
you push the button then oh here's what
the software is doing it what the
circuits are doing yeah yeah yeah so I
mean if you think about it you know any
well-written document is hierarchical
right a textbook will have an
introduction and each chapter will have
an introduction and there's all of these
different levels of summarization in
good in a good textbook or other source
of knowledge and that's what's lacking
in a discussion so we're basically
trying to get back what is if you have a
carefully edited artifact it will
naturally have the structure already and
yes you can imagine wanting to make
things sort of expandable instead of
having it all laid out linearly in order
to simplify the reading process but the
challenge with online discussions is
that there so is that there is no
individual providing that that
organization at the beginning and so you
have to figure out how to lay it on
later yeah yeah so again one of one of
the open questions is sorry did I have
it on the slide was quality control
right so you know in our in our
discussion sometimes people wrote
terrible summaries right and as I said
nobody changed them but there needs to
be ways for people to maybe moderate
summaries like upload them are down both
them request that they be rewritten to
sort of so but we've also talked about
allowing competing summaries to be
written and then like letting people
sort of vote on which one they like
better and so forth no keeps changing
this is a cultural issue right like
Wikipedia there is a culture of
continuous improvement of all of the
content right well right well so that's
actually where we're pointing Wickham is
is - the kind of things that happen on
top pages on Wikipedia which are again I
mean their wiki pages technically they
can be edited but in fact they just grow
linearly and people keep tacking things
on right so people know that you edit
the wiki page and they don't edit the
top page yeah
no raises like it's one thing if you if
you're if you're dealing with
engineering and it's quite another if
you're dealing with Shakespeare right
word one interpretation might not be any
better than it is
oh yeah it's a great point and it is one
that we that we are thinking about sort
of and it goes again into this sort of
richer hypertext issue right so maybe it
shouldn't be a tree right maybe you want
to have multiple parents of different
pieces of content because there are
these multiple interpretations or
multiple summarizations actually yeah I
think I cut that slide but I'm
interested more generally in sort of
argumentation systems for first sort of
people to say we're having a debate so
here's this point that I want to make
and here is evidence supporting the
point and here is here is evidence
contradicting your point and you know
here's how I can you know if I take
these three points then I can draw the
following inference and and so forth I
think there is some wonderful rich
structure there it's very challenging to
think about how to present it to normal
human beings who are not logicians or
philosophers in a way that is going to
make sense but that's a direction that
I'm hoping to to go in oh yes so there
it is right there at the bottom so
capturing notions of assertion and
evidence and disagreement and and so
forth so these are both special kinds of
hypertext but hypertext
I mean the web is hypertext but it isn't
really we're not somehow using the all
of the incredible richness of hypertext
for nonlinear text and narrative and I
think part of the reason is that there's
this phrase of being lost in hyperspace
and there are lots of cartoons about it
in Wikipedia right you start here and
you always end up on elephants or
something because so these two tools
provide a sort of limited hypertext
right there's this notion of there's
there's the core content and there's the
margins and everything is attached from
the margins to the core content where
the some wickham provides this tree so
you have a down and an up and you don't
get lost
between down and up so what other kinds
of restrictions on hypertext can we use
in order to help people be more able to
navigate through it and benefit from the
nonlinear structure so for example when
NB was used in a law class the students
right they wrote these three-page
annotations and so of course other
students wanted to annotate the
annotations right so how do we do that
do we have a margin on the margin do we
let you sort of drag an annotation into
the center pane and now the sidebar
becomes the annotations on that Center
thing but you can still go back to the
original content and then there would
still be a sort of tree structure in
terms of layers of annotation so really
interesting questions there I'll mention
now the latest thing we're working on
which is a structured news sharing
platform and this was inspired by a sort
of weird phenomenon on Facebook I
started getting a lot of anti backspace
and it turned out that the reason was
that one of my friends who's a doctor
was commenting on them explaining that
they were wrong and so for Facebook this
is a sign of engagement which means that
those posts should be surfaced and shown
to more people which is exactly what the
doctor was saying they shouldn't be
doing right and so the problem is that
Facebook only has a notion of this is a
comment it doesn't have any notion of
the meaning of the comment the valence
what what is the purpose of that comment
so we're trying out to build a new news
sharing platform where the structure
that is incorporated is who do you trust
what is true and how do you know and so
these are now parts of the data model in
this news sharing platform so a person
using this platform will create a list
of people and organizations that they
trust and when you post something you
are expected to indicate whether you
consider it to be accurate or or sorry
when you see a comment you can indicate
whether or when you see a post you can
indicate whether you believe it to be
accurate or inaccurate and you can also
explain and you are required to also
explain what is your reason right were
you an eyewitness to this to this issue
or are you an expert on the topic or do
you just hope it's true because it makes
you feel good
and users are going to have to annotate
in this way now we're focusing on
annotating whole articles although we
might bring in some of the env style
annotation later
um and then once you've got this we can
we can now sort of digest this
information and say okay this article is
rated as true by a bunch of people who
you trust so we will show you that
article in your feed
this budge this article is rated as
false so we will not show it
this article is disputed so we will flag
that it is disputed and we will see if
we can get you to help resolve the
dispute by providing your own input on
whether it is true or false this is a
screenshot of the current prototype
we're still prototyping the design we're
not I mean it's partially functional but
we're certainly not done yet and so
we're giving you filters on sort of
different different kinds of content
that you might want to look at right you
may want to look at the debated content
in order to contribute your own opinions
or you might want to take it easy and
just look at things that are known to be
true based on your trust network so here
you know we've got posts and over here
we're showing you which people have
indicated that or which entities have
indicated them to be true so that you
can decide if you want to believe them
you can also navigate to a particular
entity and look at what they have rated
to be true so that you can decide maybe
it's a new entity whether you want to
trust them or not and so and that's a
detail of the prototype right so yes
that is an article that I have marked as
being true and so that's showing in the
system yes that is correct
I mean we infer that right so so you
know Fox is not a user of our system but
we infer that the poster is asserting
that that something is true okay yeah so
you said that all right so that was sort
of structure let me sort of race you
through work we're doing on richer
workflows so what do I mean about richer
workflows is that sometimes you know
you're getting these massive amounts of
content and you don't have capacity to
consume or organize all of that content
so what can we do about that
so we've looked at that in the context
of mailing lists first and we asked the
question of why they're still here right
and at the same time what's wrong with
them and how can we fix it so you know
email started in 1967 the first mailing
list was created in 1971 obviously it
was recursive to discuss what mailing
lists could be used for and they haven't
changed since right it is still exactly
the same as the 1971 mailing list there
are so many new tools out there all of
the social media platforms for
discussion what else has survived for 40
years unchanged right not much
so we asked why mailing lists are still
here there must be something good about
them if they've survived so long but
people always complaining about them so
what's wrong with them and can we take
the good bits and get rid of the bad
bits and I'm not going to tell you too
much about how we did the study because
that will take too much time basically
we found a couple of mailing lists and
interviewed people on those mailing
lists we asked people to compare them to
the social media platforms we found out
that yes lots of people do use mailing
lists and none of them wanted to switch
their traffic to the social media
platforms why do they prefer mailing
lists over social media well they think
email is much more serious than social
media they feel that if they move to
social media they start seeing cat
videos on their mailing lists which they
don't want they also felt that email was
more of a private environment only used
by the participants on the mailing list
whereas something like Facebook big
brother is watching and everybody else
in the world is watching in fact it
turned out that both of the mailing
lists that we were using were public and
archived so anybody in the world could
have read anything on either of the
mailing lists but when we told them that
they didn't care I felt that even though
they were technically public nobody was
actually looking they also felt that
email is more likely to be seen by the
target
than social media where there's these
opaque tools for deciding who gets to
see what and they also especially liked
that they could customize their email
management right this was they this came
back a lot right I can move my messages
into different folders I can have
filtering rules all of these things that
you can't do on social media because the
user is not in control then we asked
about the problems with these mailing
lists and we found three sort of really
interesting tensions which are all
caused by the fact that a mailing list
has more than one person on it and
everybody has different opinions about
how you should do mail so people had
disagreements about what should be on
the mailing list right again people mail
mail goes to everybody it's not like
social media right so you kind of have
to have a communal decision about what
is going to be on the mailing list so on
one of our mailing lists we had some
people saying oh the good old days when
there were these wonderful wide-ranging
discussions on the mailing list and then
you had other people saying thank God
they stopped with those long discussions
on the mailing list right and so you
know a third of the people wanted less
discussion on their mailing lists a
third of the people wanted more
discussion on their mailing lists we
also had these interesting fights over
how important should it be before you
put it on the mailing list some people
were like well you know I saw a cat I
should tell my lab and other people are
like I hate it when people hit reply all
and instead of just replying to the one
person who asked the question we also
saw these tensions over some people who
wanted more interaction in the community
versus people who were afraid that
everybody else in the community did not
like having too much interaction I've
seen this in other systems that we built
too is that all of these participants
wanted more but were afraid that other
people wanted less and in fact 66% of
the people who wanted more discussion on
their mailing lists had never actually
participated in one because they were
afraid of bothering everybody else right
so you don't want to span large audience
you don't want to be misinterpreted you
don't want to generate heated arguments
you don't want to look stupid
the last tension was over these sort of
mental models of what of how a man
this works so some people had this sort
of pull model which says that the
content goes out there is like Clay
Shirky publish and filter write the
content goes out there and then people
can select what they want to read right
so this is sort of the social media
mental model right other people had the
push model that senders are forcing
recipients to receive content and so
this is what traditional email is about
and depending on which mental model
people had they'd had different desires
and preferences around the mailing list
right the the pull people they had to
tend to have automatic filtering rules
that would put their stuff into folders
for them and so they would sometimes not
even read that email because it just
went into a folder that they didn't look
at and they would sort of time when they
read different topics by looking at
different folders at different time the
people with the push model they just had
their inbox and so they read everything
when it arrived and they really hated
missing emails they wanted to be on top
of everything and sort of you got these
different perspectives right the pull
people were like well I can post
something else because everybody's just
filtering it into I'm not bothering them
by posting but the people who use push
we're really leery about sending an
email because they assumed everybody
else have this push model as well
so in summary email has this appeal it's
more serious more private you know who's
reading it and you know that they are
reading it as opposed to missing it and
you have more control over how do we
didn't organize it on the flip side
there are these tensions where everybody
disagrees about how much content should
actually be going on that mailing list
and how do people consume it and really
this a lot of it is about control right
each person wants to control their
inflow of information
everybody wants to control it
differently and there's sort of this
negotiation that has to happen between
multiple parties so in order to address
this we've been trying to build a new
mailing this platform called murmur
which gives people more control over
what they are going to receive on a
mailing list and again this is up you
can play with it you might ask why we're
doing this instead of social media but
I've been explaining to you that people
care a lot about mailing lists and it
also tends to be easier to work with
email like we don't have to understand
the api's for these different social
media platforms we
need to write a tool that talks I'm app
and it works but and everybody gets to
keep using their favorite email client
they don't have to change anything and
so we've designed in a lot of things
based on these interviews right so
people can for example say that they
only want to get the first post on a
thread and have the system not put
anything else into their mailbox
unless they indicate that they're
interested in that post we're also
incorporating from social media things
like tagging a message and uploading it
and now we let people write rules like
only put this in my inbox if it gets
more than ten upvotes
or you know get look at all emails from
this person but don't look at emails
from this person and so forth to give
them more of that control that that they
would like to have yeah so ignore Adam
because you know he's always posting
silly things but we also try and design
for reluctant senders so this worry
about spamming everybody on the mailing
list what can we do about that well we
can allow senders to intentionally limit
distribution so one model is we send
this when you post something it only
goes to a few people and if they upload
it it goes to more people okay but now
it's not a it's not the system deciding
to do this it's the sender deciding to
do this right and so this can encourage
them to not that they're not spanning
everybody but giving people an
opportunity to say that they're
interested in it right or they people
can follow on consent only to thing that
people who are following a particular
tag or you can send to everybody except
a certain troll on the mailing list who
always complains when you post things
right now there's interesting question
about whether that's ethical right if
you have a if you have a community
mailing list should you be allowed to
send to everybody except one person I
think that's kind of interesting another
really interesting thing that we saw was
and this inspired an another project was
people were afraid of looking stupid and
this was specifically some people with
from with with limited english-speaking
capabilities they wanted when they sent
something for it to go to a few of their
friends who would check it and block it
if it was not a good idea to send to the
mailing list
but would otherwise allow it through and
it would go to everybody so this again
addressed sort of sender reluctance I
see him over time so I'm just gonna
mention that we then took this in
another sort of direction where we
looked at email harassment so one of the
things that's very common in online
harassment is to try and get your
friends to help out and the way this is
currently done is people give their
friends the passwords to their social
media accounts and they ask them to
actually go in and clean up their like
to delete all of the nasty posts before
the person comes and actually reads
their reads their messages the theory I
think is that a harassing message
directed at me is not going to have the
same impact on my friends as we discover
this a quite common and so we've built a
system called squad box let me just show
you the icon which provides a workflow
scaffold for your friends so basically
what squad box does is it intercepts
email that's being sent to you and it
puts it into a moderation queue that
your friends can look at and it's we
interviewed a lot of harassment victims
and discovered that they have many
different ways of dealing with the
harassment what they want done with the
messages how they want them annotated or
organized which ones should be sent and
which ones should go on and to the
recipient and which ones should not all
of that is stuff that's captured in the
squad box workflow model so that you
don't have to give people the passwords
to your to your social media accounts
anymore instead they have a system that
is specifically dedicated to handling
this moderation workflow and squad boxes
up as well and you can if if there is
god forbid anybody who's who's suffering
from harassment who you know this tool
is available and and ready to use
our preliminary experiments show that
it's quite usable and and and people
like it so I'd love for I'd love for us
to find some people who we can help out
with this tool all right so I think I'll
conclude
with that we've got other other sort of
workflow projects as well but I can talk
to you about those tomorrow when we when
we meet let me just conclude with the
sort of message that I gave at the
beginning which is that our current
computer tools are too limiting they
don't have the representations or the
workflows that people are perfectly
capable of and in fact desire to use to
manage their information and there are
many opportunities to make things better
by written rich in the data models and
enriching the workflows that will
support what people actually want to do
now you might object that all of this
control is too complicated that
everybody wants it and nobody will use
it but in fact I believe there is this
sort of theory of what's called the
Gardiners that there always a few people
who are willing to put in the extra time
to understand tools better and do more
interesting things with them I think if
we can empower them it will improve the
quality of information for for everyone
who's making use of that information and
so it looks like in the editing of my
slides I lost the thank you slide so
that's the end thank you very much
[Applause]